there's frustration all over britain
with the ongoing fuel cues in this
crisis caused by a shortage of truck
drivers in a few days many tankers are
likely to have soldiers at the wheel
they're being trained up now as an
emergency measure
an opportune backdrop of public descent
you might think for kier stama the
leader of labor britain's main
opposition party
this is undoubtedly the most important
speech of his career level
up you can't even fill up
prime minister
either get a grip
or get out of the way and let us step up
and clear up this mess
he may have been ready for the heckling
from left wingers however he's failed to
win the full confidence of his party and
it would seem the country too
in 2019 his predecessor jeremy corbyn
led the party to its worst defeat since
1935.
corbyn's left-wing policies have gone
the same way as he did out
but a split in the party hasn't been
fixed
starmer has to make a stand now with
internal reform of the party and what
his supporters regard as a relaunch
i say these simple
but powerful words
we will never under my leadership go
into an election with a manifesto that
is not a serious plan for government
stammer was a lawyer who became the
director of public prosecutions before
going into politics he's pledged to give
the police the extra manpower and
resources they need and to come down
harder on violent crime
and throughout his speech he tried
personalizing his politics referring to
his humble beginnings as the son of a
tool maker
some more bold promises came on
education thousands of new teaching jobs
much more investment a reminder perhaps
of better times
education education and education
could starma emulate the early years of
tony blair who took labour to centrist
politics that won over voters
the next election isn't due until 2024
for this former prosecutor the jury may
still be out but his supporters are
hoping he can appeal to the wider public
and lead labour back into power after
more than a decade in opposition
andrew simmons al jazeera